let's talk a little bit about voter
fraud and voter suppression we've been
talking for years at this point about
how the right claims voter fraud is the
problem with elections meaning people
showing up and voting twice voting for
dead people all sorts of antics
happening in person whereas people who
understand reality have been saying
actually it's election fraud that's the
problem it's voter suppression that's
the problem voter fraud is really rare
it's mostly Republicans trying to prove
how easy it is to do it and getting
caught voter suppression on the other
hand is rampant reductions in voting
hours reductions in polling places voter
IDs voter purges from voter rolls very
very long list
we finally have a story about really
serious voter suppression we found an
example finally and it's Republicans in
North Carolina and it's important to
point out that I'm colloquially calling
this we finally found the voter fraud
that Republicans are talking about
strictly speaking this is actually
election fraud because voter fraud is
fearmonger by Republicans basically
doesn't exist and the story goes to
North Carolina's ninth district where
Republican Mark Harris supposedly
defeated the Democratic opponent Dan
McReady by nine hundred and five votes
out of two hundred and eighty thousand
votes cast the Board of Elections
however decided not to certify Harris's
win because of suspicious voter
suppression that they noticed they
noticed that in some counties the
Republican one really a strangely high
portion of the mail-in absentee ballots
and the results were drastically
different than in other counties the
numbers just really didn't make sense
there are now allegations that are
hopefully going to be investigated which
are just stunning number one people are
claiming that those that people showed
up at their door saying I'm here to
collect your absentee ballot and in fact
ginger Eason has admitted that Leslie
McCray Dallas junior paid her between 75
and a hundred bucks to pick up completed
absentee ballots in the ninth district
she never mailed the ballots but handed
them to Dallas which is against the law
multiple people physically handling
absentee ballots instead of them being
mailed in as they're supposed to be
Dallas has twice been named in sworn
affidavits as someone working for the
Republican candidates campaign Dallas is
not denying it
Dallas was asked for comment and said no
comment also very suspicious the same
people have been signing as witnesses
for people voting on absentee ballots it
is very strange why are the same people
acting as witnesses for so many voters
on their absentee ballots unrequested
absentee ballots have been arriving at
people's houses improper election
monitoring has been reported at polling
places unusual coding of absentee
ballots multiple people have overheard
others talking about payments to a local
political operative working for the
Republican candidate 538 said let's run
a statistical analysis on the results
and without getting into the full math
of it the percentages of absentee
ballots in some counties versus others
relative to the portion of all ballots
that went for Republicans versus
Democrats are making no sense
politically and they're making no sense
mathematically so I don't know what
happens next because the election wasn't
certified the North Carolina Republican
Party is threatening to sue if the
results don't get certified and it's
it's sort of unclear what happens next
but we found it ladies and gentlemen we
got'em pat it's election fraud it's in
North Carolina it's by Republicans but
of course this isn't the type of fraud
that they want to talk about they want
to talk about your neighbor down the
street voting three times as if that's
even a way to flip an election right and
if people like Donald Trump and Kris
Kobach we're serious about election
integrity this would be Exhibit A for
them but no they just they want to take
a look at supposed voter fraud committed
by Hispanic people or young people
people likely to vote for Democrats
it's more of a political affiliation
thing than anything else
Republicans finally have themselves a
fraudulent voting story but they don't
want to talk about it because it's all
them and I hope that we don't let this
go and we actually get to the bottom of
it send me your thoughts the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I am on
Twitter at Dee Pakman and I look forward
to hearing from you today's episode of
the David Pakman show sponsored in part
by stamps.com
this is the time of year where the post
office gets very very busy which is why
I've been using stamps.com
for years because I want to save time
during the hectic time of year at the
post office but still get all of the
great US Postal Service services that
they offer
which we love stamps.com brings this to
your desktop to your laptop buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package any class of mail using your
own computer and your own printer and
then the mail carrier will pick it up
print postage any day any time this
saves you time this also saves you money
because stamps calm helps you print the
right amount of postage every time no
overpaying because you're estimating how
many stamps you've got to put on that
envelope and with all the time and money
you'll save
stamps.com is a really great gift that
you can give yourself this holiday
season we've been using stamps.com for
years to mail out david pakman show
calendars david pakman show bumper
stickers and coffee mugs and all sorts
of stuff and right now you can also
enjoy the stamps.com service with a
special offer four week trial plus
postage and a free digital scale with no
long term commitment go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in pakman that's
stamps.com type in PA que ma n at the
radio microphone at the top of the page